okay hey everyone it's uh Mike Bal again
I'm the founder and Trader at order
flows.com
and this is the orderflows Delta scalper
with Goldman Sachs and CME stock for
August 30th
2016 first a brief disclaimer um even
though this presentation is about
equities uh this is my standard Futures
disclaimer which basically
says P performance not necessar
indicative of future results and don't
trade without uh with money that you
need to live on um you know only risk
Capital should be used for trading and
only those with sufficient risk Capital
should consider trading don't trade with
the rent
money the tools used in this
presentation are the orderflows Delta
scalper it runs on the ninja Trader
trading
platform you can download ninjatrader
for free at www. ninjatrader
docomo is available on my website for a
small onetime charge and yeah yesterday
I was talking about Apple
stock
um um the other day you
know I I you know there's been interest
in orderflow indicators on Equity
markets and you know the three stocks
that I've I used to look at used to
follow were CME apple and Goldman Sachs
well and JP Morgan but uh that that
stock is always struggling um and I know
people that have been you know worked
for Bank One before Bank One became part
of JP Morgan and I think they're St are
still underwater from you know the 9s uh
but anyway yeah that stock is a bit of a
of a leer um honly I haven't even looked
at that stock price in a long time
um the only thing that keeps me off of
JP Morgan stock is you know the fact
that they're always paying out these big
lawsuits billion here five billion there
10 billion there um you know imagine
what their earnings would be if they if
they weren't keep getting fined all the
time um but anyway uh so again you know
the other day I ran the delta scalper in
real time on on CME Goldman Sachs and
Apple stock and the other day it gave
some very nice signals in the in Apple
shares and nothing in the CME and golden
Sach stocks
now I said I'm not a stock guy I'm a
Futures guy trade Futures but you know
if these will work on stocks you know I
think that would be a great tool that
that Traders can use and yesterday uh
August 30th
there was
ironically signals in the CME and
signals in Goldman Sachs and there was
no signals in apple which you know the
other day there was a signal in apple
signals in apple but uh no signals in
Goldman sacks or CME but
anyway you know I mean you can only
trade what the market gives you if
doesn't give you any signs then you know
there's no reason to trade and what
happened was this is a CME stock um from
August 30th around 11:20 you get a nice
Buy Signal here this is uh what was that
the 10685 10690
level and it shot straight up you know
the
10720 10 you know above 10715 for quite
a while yeah it did come off tested back
down to the 10690 10685 is area before
taken off you know for the rest of the
day now you know I'm not someone that's
going to say yeah you could have bought
here and sold up here I mean honestly if
the way I trade I catch this move starts
to come off like this this is where I'm
getting out
you know maybe I write it down a little
bit here and you know get out here but
I'm not looking you know I said on the
one minut chart I'm not going to buy it
at 11:20 and hold it until 2:00 in the
afternoon I mean come on it's a one
minute chart you have to have a short
time frame view of the market you said
yeah it's beautiful when it when it
works out like this but I mean be
realistic if you're trading a one minute
chart you're not looking to to find a
signal on a one minute chart and hold it
the entire day that's just nuts you know
there's people that maybe do that I
don't know but not me you know get a
nice a nice shoot up right here you it's
a nice profit you know you can get out
you know just start to come off a little
bit here you know maybe you you hold it
down to here and wait for something come
back up you know you know where your you
know your stop is below this level so
you know even if you um you know want to
hold it you know for as long as you can
you know your stop should be just below
your entry price ideally I mean what you
know real istically you should be
trailing your stop and you know if
you're getting out you know if your stop
is down here below 10685 you wouldn't
have been stopped out you could have
caught that move but again that's not my
style of trading you
know depending if there was any signs in
the order flow I said you know I'm an
orderflow Trader I look at volume
footprint charts I like to see signs in
the volume footprint of you know maybe
the Market's coming off but um you know
have a hard time now going back to the
normal bar charts but when I see things
like you know golfing you know something
like this red bar right here at the the
end of a move you know usually that's a
sign for me to get out um you know based
on on Candlestick analysis but you know
realistically 10715 I mean you're
looking at a nice move there you know
very quick you know you're in and out
you know 20 minutes not even you know 15
minutes is you know you can be in the
trade and you know but not all trades
worked out Goldman Sachs this trade
didn't work out um you know this was
what time is at about
12:35 Chicago time um you know we had
the swing High start coming off coming
off then you got a sign in here a Buy
Signal and it didn't work out it stopped
you out you got stopped out here I mean
I'm not going to not show this chart you
because it's a loss I'm going to show it
because you know this is the one signal
you got then it didn't work out now you
know getting back to knowing how to
trade right you wish every signal would
be like you know like the CME stock
right you wish every day would be like
this but unfortunately there's days like
this now you know having a decent you
know stop price your your entry price is
somewhere in here 10 167 I don't know
what that is 85 you know maybe have a
stop you know at 16780 you know give it
a little bit of space down here you get
stopped out are you willing to risk you
know this you know this right here this
little uh stop price you know to get to
get moves like this you know or even I I
say I don't want to say this I mean that
just looks too good but you know are you
willing to risk you know have a tight
stop like this you know potentially
catch moves like this you know right
here from 106 you know 90 will call it
to 10715 within a few minutes yeah I I
would take these types of Trades all day
long take the small loss to catch you
know take a a five with stocks moving
you know a 5cent
loss you know to catch you know a 30
Cent
winner I would do that all day long
every day um you know for the rest of my
life um I mean I do that actually in the
equities sorry in the uh in the Futures
you know I have relatively tight stops
and you know but you have to have stops
in I mean yeah people say well yeah it
came down and then went back up I mean
you're not going to have a stop way down
here you know your entry signal is in
you know 106 167 85 is area or 90 I
can't see on this chart right here
clearly but uh you know it's somewhere
in here but you know really you know it
never was in your favor and it just
stopped you out right away these are the
best types of stops I I think the ones
that just stop you out right away I I
don't like the ones that sort of go
sideways on you um I I prefer to you
know either make the move up you know
when you're buying like this or just
come out and stop you out pretty quick
and you know move on get get it out of
the system and you know just look for
the next trade so you know the day
before there was we look at the video
from the day before with Apple
stock you know there's some very nice
winners today there was a nice winner in
the CME and you know a small loser in
Golden
Sachs so I mean if if you can't add you
know if if you're interested in a Delta
scalper you can just visit my website um
you know orderflows decom and you can
find out more information about it again
you know I said it's this is only two
days of analysis you know on three
stocks you know so it's by no means is
it a comprehensive analysis that you
should go out and start trading around I
you should try and test it more and
watch for more examples you know I'm
going to know going forward yeah I'm
going to be watching more examples of
this so and you know hopefully things
will uh you know appear like this I said
you know I'm a Futures guy but hell if
you know if I'm getting moves like this
you know daily on on stocks I'm going to
be all over it you know I mean
I hate to you know I spent 20 years in
the Futures industry but
honestly you know these are nice signals
um you know this one yeah that's fine
you know I'm fine you know I mean not
every trade is going to be a winner you
know people will run it on something and
think oh you know hey lost money on this
trade yeah so what I mean you have
losers I hate to I don't like to say you
know it sounds very cliche uh losing is
part of doing business you know I hate
losers so what I want to do is I want to
minimize the loss I want to contain them
you know as as small as possible and I
want to have the winners be nice big
Winners so you know again to uh you know
just to sum up I said you know it's been
only two days on watching stocks but uh
you know so far the the results have
been very uh very encouraging I'm going
to start watching more somebody sent me
an email with uh you know how to find
some decent stocks I got decent volume
coming into the day so I'm going to
start uh looking at that a bit more and
sort of broaden out my uh my analysis so
again you know thanks for watching this
video to learn more about the trading
softwares that I use in this
presentation and how you can profit from
orderflow Trading visit www. orderflows
docomo which is the tool that I used in
this video is you can see it on on my
website orderflows I have a standalone
website called Deltas scaler.com as well
I should probably put that
uh the link is is below this video
anyway so if you want to watch it you
want to check it out go ahead um you
know but he I mean honestly you know
days like this you know this is
beautiful this and to me this is
beautiful I said I I said you know I
like to have tight stops and I like to
get stopped out if I'm going to get
stopped out I want it to be fairly soon
um I hate these long drawn out trades
you know if it gave me a Buy Signal and
it just sort of sputtered like this down
here uh I wouldn't like that i' I'd
prefer if I get stopped out it it happen
quick it's like pulling a Band-Aid off
of off of a wound you know you want to
peel it off slowly or you just want to
rip it right off and be done with it um
to me this is ripping the Band-Aid right
off um you know uh an old colleague of
mine from Homer Bank uh Papa aino you
guys probably see him on on CNBC and and
wber and stuff like that but uh yeah he
he you know we talking about errors
and losses and you know you're going to
have trading errors you know trading
losses and it's going to be a certain
percentage of your trades and if you get
that you know that error that loss out
of your system then hey that's great
so you should be looking forward to your
next trade because you know you just had
a a losing
trade you know so ideally you know if
you're playing the percentages you know
you should start looking forward to some
winners now of course you know that
that's not mathematically sound you know
I friend who I tried to explain that to
who's one of these math Geeks and just
sits there and shakes his head but you
know what in in
trading things like that keep you going
um you know it's that belief that you
know you're looking for you have this
losing trade okay you get down but you
know maybe just right around the corner
you're going to get a nice trade like
this um you know if you're pessimist you
know trading is probably not for you um
you know up it it's better to be an
optimistic person than than uh than a
pessimistic person when it comes to
trading so anyway um you know thanks
thanks for watching this video and I'll
see you on the inside bye-bye